das ist natürlich ein sehr wichtiges
Thema und greift ja eigentlich in die
anderen Themen auch im Wesentlichen ein
es geht ja im sage ich mal einmal
natürlich um die Arbeitnehmer die sich
eben immer mehr fragen wenn immer mehr
Abzüge eben kommen lohnt sich das eines
Tages überhaupt noch hier ich sag mal zu
arbeiten dann ist es aber auch ein Thema
was natürlich eben die Unternehmen
trifft die langsam Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
einbüßen ich habe eben viel Zeit im
Ausland verbracht Deutschland war immer
so eine Vorbildfunktion ja wir waren
Exportweltmeister die ganze Welt hat
eben sage ich mal nach unseren Produkten
nachgefragt und unsere Dienstleistungen
und heute kommen dann Fragen aus dem
Ausland was ist bei euch in dem Land
eigentlich jetzt los ja und wir wir
spielen gerade ich sag mal
die Position und das muss man bedenken
die uns nach dem zweiten weltkriegt nach
USA und Japan zu drittgrößten
Wirtschaftsnation dieser Erde gemacht
hat also das war ja ein sehr sehr gutes
Erfolgsmodell eben diese soziale
Marktwirtschaft sie hat funktioniert und
jetzt stottert Motor seit einigen Jahren
Stadt hat eben immer mehr und und eben
konsumentenfragen sich eben eben geht
das noch und ich habe ja eben sehr viel
Kontakt auch mit mit jungen Menschen
wenn wir jetzt heute mal den
Arbeitsmarkt uns anschauen dann wissen
wir ja wir haben diesen demografischen
Wandel der kommt auf uns zu es werden in
den nächsten Jahren die Babyboomer
Generation eben aufhören zu arbeiten und
dann
kommen viel weniger Menschen in den
Arbeitsmarkt rein das heißt wir brauchen
Fachkräfte aus dem Ausland
aber ich verspüre bei jungen Leuten
heute eher eine Tendenz weil das
bedeutet natürlich demografischer Wandel
die Abgaben steigen weiter das heißt
also dass das Netto wurde eben noch
weniger und da ist es dann eben so dass
heute glaube ich eben in der junge
Menschen hier auch immer mehr darüber
nachdenken ich habe hier eine Ausbildung
eine Ausbildung gemacht ein Studium
vielleicht gemacht aber vielleicht
arbeite ich jetzt im Ausland so wie sie
auch sie sind in die Schweiz gegangen
und sie bereuen das natürlich auch kein
Stück nein also das also ich muss sagen
also das war 1999 bin ich mit meiner
Familie in die Schweiz gezogen und ich
sag heute das war eine der besten
Entscheidungen meines Lebens weil ich
immer die Schweizer und wir Deutsche
sind relativ ähnlich wir sprechen eben
zumindestens im Nordteil dieselbe
Sprache die Wirtschaft funktioniert eben
auch relativ gleich aber eben die die
Abgaben die man in der Schweiz eben als
Arbeitnehmer oder auch als Unternehmer
zu tragen hat sind deutlich niedriger
ich meine wir haben ja nach der OECD
praktisch ja auch da zahlen dass ich
glaube Deutschland und Belgien die
beiden Länder sind wo Arbeitseinkommen
mit am höchsten weltweit belastet sind
und ich glaube bei den Unternehmen
Steuern dann sieht es ja ähnlich ähm
düster aus also auch dort
singt ja unsere Wettbewerbsfähigkeit das
ist uns einmal in die Zukunft blicken wo
steht Deutschlands nach ihrer Sicht in
zehn Jahren die Wirtschaftskraft von
Deutschland ist immer noch und dann
das muss man Deutschland oder darf man
Deutschland auch nicht schlecht reden
immer noch ein sehr gutes Land und es
ist immer noch ich sag mal ja ich sag
mal sehr weit oben aber wir steigen eben
langsam ab und das kann man nach vielen
Parametern sehen wo wir eben langsam
sage ich mal eben und das hat ja uns die
Politik auch jetzt seit einem Jahr
gesagt wir werden Wohlstand verlieren
und das kam ja nicht nur aus einer
Partei das kam ja aus mehreren Parteien
und ich meine der Wohlstand eines Landes
ist ja auch ein Gradmesser woran man
sehen kann wie gut es uns geht weil ich
sag mal 80 Millionen Menschen die Summe
dieser 80 Millionen Menschen und ihr
ihren Wohlstand den sie sich vielleicht
erarbeiten können ist ja Ausdruck wie
gut es einem Land geht und da sind wir
mittlerweile weltweit auf Platz Nummer
da waren wir auch weit oben und sinken
dort also ich sag mal relativ rapide
nach unten sind die Abgaben zu hoch
Herrn zur lohnt sich das Arbeiten nicht
mehr genug in Deutschland also ich
glaube wo wir vor allem ein Problem im
Moment haben und das zeigen alle
internationalen Studien ist die
Situation der Unternehmenssteuern da ist
Deutschland hochsteuernland deswegen
haben wir richtigerweise auch trotz der
schwierigen Haushaltslage nach Corona in
unserem Wahlprogramm ja auch ein
entsprechendes entfesselungspaket
gefordert das ist nämlich nötig denn der
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland leidet
unter dieser hochsteuer Belastung und
wenn wir uns dann bei der Besteuerung
des Arbeitseinkommens die Situation
anschauen dann mache ich mir vor allem
Sorgen und das ist auch etwas was immer
mehr in den Blick der Politik geraten
muss um den normalen Bürger die hart
arbeiten der Mitte denn wir haben diese
Situation dass die Leute die in
Deutschland richtig richtig gut
verdienen die haben im Zweifel das muss
man zur Wahrheit auch sagen dann die
Möglichkeiten
in ein anderes Land zu ziehen
steuergestaltungsmodelle zu wählen die
finden schon irgendwie einen Weg und die
die dann im Bezug von Transferleistungen
sind für die wird auch gesorgt aber für
die normale hart arbeitende Mitte für
die Leute die knapp über dem Mindestlohn
verdienen die sind besonders hart
getroffen durch unser Steuersystem und
deswegen sind aus meiner Sicht da die
beiden hauptansatzpunkte Entlastungen
der Mitte und Unternehmenssteuerreform
das muss es beides geben weil sonst ist
der Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland in
Gefahr und gerade in der aktuellen Lage
die wir eben auch haben von einer
angespannten Haushaltssituation muss man
sagen
Steuerentlastungen und Steuerreform
bedeutet nicht automatisch steuern
Mindereinnahmen sondern sie können zudem
führen was wir brauchen nämlich Wachstum
das ist die Grundlage dafür dass wir
volkswirtschaftlich mehr Erträge und
dann auch wiederum mehr Steuereinnahmen
bekommen
aber gerade da sieht es ja im Moment
relativ gut aus für den Staat also was
ich in den letzten Wochen immer lese bei
dem Bürger Besitz der Gürtel immer enger
und der Staat hat eine Rekordeinnahmen
nach der anderen und jetzt dürfen wir ja
nicht vergessen als ganz großer
Schuldner ist er ja einer der ganz
großen Profiteure der hohen Inflation ja
aber der Staat hat natürlich in der
aktuellen Lage und jetzt die Details der
Haushaltspolitiker wir haben natürlich
das große Problem dass bei dieser
Regierung die redet von doppelwumms und
Co da stehen große Steuereinnahmen
natürlich auch gigantischen Ausgang
Ausgaben entgegen und man darf nicht
vergessen die Staatsverschuldung die wir
haben die es im Moment auch ein
ziemlicher Treiber der Inflation und die
politisch gewollte Niedrigzinspolitik
der EZB die holt den Staatshaushalt im
Moment mit steigenden Zinsen natürlich
auch ein deswegen ist halt wichtig dass
wir nicht auf Pump und nicht sozusagen
nur durch staatliche Leistung sondern
durch eine funktionierende Wirtschaft
und seinen stattfindet und vor allem
wollen wir natürlich jetzt auch noch mal
gearbeitet in Bürgern bleiben ja fast
wenn man fragt sich so hat dass er auch
eben gerade gesagt die die können
vielleicht umso mehr jetzt ins
auszusagen
Nachtarbeiten Mitte aber vorher noch mal
wenn Sie beide saßen dann nur 16 Jahre
in der Regierung und diese Themen die
wir jetzt gerade hier besprechen die
sind ja nun wirklich nicht neu ja und
dann haben sie wirklich schlechter
geworden ob die ob die wirklich ob die
Lage wirklich nur schlechter geworden
ist das will ich jetzt mal gar nicht
sagen aber auf die auf die auf die
Bürger mal zurückzukommen hart
arbeitende Mitte ich würde das gar nicht
mal so restriktiv sehen es gibt gerade
in der sogenannten arbeiten mit sehr
gute sehr gut ausgebildete Handwerker
die Jünger sind und die nach Kanada geht
die nach Australien die auswandern es
geht auch aus gerade aus der hart
arbeiten in Mitte viele die ihr Glück
woanders suchen und ich sehe noch eine
ganz andere
Bevölkerungsgruppe die eigentlich viel
mehr in den Fokus kommen soll wir haben
20% Kinderarmut und 20 % der Rentner die
mit weniger als 1000 ja also ich wohne
in Berlin Zehlendorf da sind um mich
herum da sind Rentner die fahren dreimal
im Jahr auf dem fremden Kontinent ja
also richtig schön weit ja und wir haben
aber 20%, wenn ich in einer Stadtteil
fahre ja die wirklich von weniger als
1000 und
nehmen wir mal eine Umfrage weil mich
jetzt gerade mit Umfragen beschäftigt
habe so ein bisschen ja nur noch 23% der
ostdeutschen und nur noch drei und 30%
der westdeutschen glauben dass es in
unserem Land sozial gerecht zugeht ja
also wenn wenn ich mir überlege wir
haben mit der SPD eine Partei die ja
sich traditionell die soziale
Gerechtigkeit da haben sie aber auch
sorry entweder sind sie nicht Schuld als
Partei entweder sind die verantwortliche
Verantwortung anders verteilt aber in
den letzten 20 30 Jahren ist die die
soziale Spaltung nur noch auseinander
gegangen und ich meine ist materiell ja
da haben wir da laufen wir in ein
riesiges Problem hinein das ist noch
meines Erachtens noch wichtiger ob die
Frage generell ob die Rente sicher ist
oder ob die die Höhe der Rente im
Durchschnitt aber 20%, die sich das
Leben nicht mehr leisten können der ganz
jung und der ganz arm das ist ein
Alarmzeichen ja das ist das und da
möchte ich auch gleich mal einen Haken
ja jetzt auch nicht als SPD Politiker
reden sondern als vorstandslos
ich mache das gerne ich war auch nicht
in die Regierung aber zumindestens im
Bundestag genau aber eins sage ich auch
mal wir machen ja sozialrechtsberatung
und bei uns laufen gerade unsere
Mitglieder uns quasi unsere
Beratungsstellen ein weil die alle
furchtbare Angst haben die hatten Angst
vor dem Winter weil sie gedacht haben
sie können in ihre Energiekosten nicht
bezahlen fliegen aus ihren Wohnungen
möglicherweise raus haben wir übrigens
auch gefordert dass es auf jeden Fall so
ein mietmoratorium geben muss dass eben
für die Zeit der Krise dass das nicht
passiert dass man Strom und gassperren
auch einbauen muss das ist ja alles so
und sie haben das gesagt die Kinderarmut
das treibt mich auch um das ist wo wir
auch übrigens gerade als Sozialverband
sagen Herr Abenteuer das können sie mir
bestimmt sagen wo bleibt die Kinder
Grundsicherung das ist etwas wo man
gerade den Menschen wirklich und wir
haben sehr viele arme Kinder und auch
arme Familien logisch kinderarmut ist
auch immer älteren Armut wo bleibt denn
diese Kindergrundsicherung dass man da
jetzt plötzlich anfängt das war jetzt
nicht ihre Partei sondern der
Finanzminister da darum zu merken und zu
sagen kein Konzept bitte das wäre eine
Möglichkeit um die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger ganz konkret zu entlassen und die
energiepreispauschale wenn ich das noch
sagen darf die war natürlich Gold wert
dass wir ein bisschen dafür sorgen
mussten dass die Rentnerinnen und
Rentner das auch bekommen das waren die
Sozialverbände die das gemacht haben
ja gerne auch natürlich und für mich ist
sie und sie haben das gerade gesagt mit
den Strompreisen natürlich wir kümmern
uns um die armen Menschen aber die sind
im Moment wirklich hilflos und sehr
verängstigt und das finde ich und das
wirst Du uns politisch alle
interessieren was passiert denn mit
diesen Menschen wenn man Pech haben dann
machen die in die großen Arme der lieben
AFD liebt sind sie nicht also der
rechtsextreme AFD und da müssen wir doch
aufpassen und deswegen müssen wir da
auch zusammen arbeiten
ja mir gerade so diskutiert über den
Wirtschaftsstandort in Deutschland und
wie sehr der gerade zu leiden hat all
den Menschen die jetzt diese Armut droht
würde doch genau das Tor zustimmen diese
Probleme legen wir dann in den Griff
wenn die Wirtschaft brummt weil wenn die
Wirtschaft brummt dann haben wir
Arbeitsplätze dann haben wir eben
Steuerzahler dann haben wir
Beitragszahler in die in die Kranken und
Altersvorsorgesysteme und dann können
wir das eben anpacken und abbauen ja
also aber da sind wir doch jetzt auch
mal ganz ehrlich also der Mindestlohn 12
Euro dass der damals eingeführt wurde da
hätte ich mir ja quasi die Hand ins
Feuer für gelegt dass das nicht passiert
wir haben es gemacht 12 Euro die Stunde
das ist ja auch nicht Armut sicher das
muss man auch mal klar sagen der müsste
eigentlich viel viel höher sein aber
müssen wir dann nicht auch darüber reden
dass vielleicht auch die Löhne
möglicherweise in diesem Land einfach zu
niedrig sind denn hohe Löhne oder gute
Löhne würden übrigens auch eine gute
Rente zu dem Thema kommen wir ja gleich
auch noch garantieren und da denke ich
immer so was passiert denn jetzt da
gerade warum will man genau darüber
nicht reden und bei uns sind die Leute
ich habe die alleinerziehende Mutter mit
ihren drei kleinen Kindern die da sitzt
und am Wochenende nur noch Raviolis ist
weil sie sich einfach in den Kühlschrank
nicht voll machen kann weil sie kein
Geld mehr für die Lebensmittel hat
deswegen und gerade diese Menschen in
Not brauchen ja auch vor allem eins gute
Politiker die gute Politik machen da
sind wir uns mit Sicherheit alle einig
wurden sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
vielen vielen Dank
Bild kämpft für Sie